bonjour et bienvenue pour ce 2e numéro
des municipal 2014 le rendez-vous
politique mensuel de la rédaction de
TVfil 78 bonjour Wilfried bonjour
Catherine nous avons convié aujourd'hui
les 7 maires de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en yeline à venir évoquer
leur position pour mars 2014 en tout cas
leur état d'esprit deux ont répondu à
notre invitation certains étaient
empêché comme le maire de Montini que
l'on entendra dans quelques instants une
interview que nous avons enregistré il y
a quelques jours d'autres ont estimé en
revanche qu'il était encore trop tôt
pour en parler bonjour Jean-Michel
Fourgous vous êtes le maire UMP
d'élancour ancien député de la 11e
circonscription des iblin de 93 à 97
puis de 2002 à 2012 mare depuis 1996 et
avant vous un socialiste àin d'année
entre 77 et 95 Bertrand ouon bonjour
alors vous vous êtes le maire socialiste
de manilé hamoau en mars 2008 lors des
dernières élections municipales vous
n'étiez pas maire mais vous étiez maire
adjoint au logement à la petite enfance
et puis Jacques L qui avait été maire
depuis 1983 vous a passé la main en
cours de mandat c'était en septembre
dernier et puis nous aurons d'ailleurs
l'occasion d'entendre pendant cette
émission les anciens maires comme
Jacques lolios et puis aussi pierre
séincour qui ont fait le choix de se
retirer avant mars 2014 une première
question pour débuter forcément
êtes-vous candidat êtes-vous déjà en
campagne Jean-Michel Fourgous non euh on
je suis pas encoreme quand vous êtes
sortant non en général on démar une
campagne 3 4 mois avant mais vous serez
candidat en tout cas oui je serai
candidat oui en ce qui vous concerne
pour manilamoot très certainement après
aujourd'hui on est là pour travailler
pour notre ville en tant que maire et
l'heure est pas aux discussions d'une
campagne politique et même quand on
travaille encore pour sa commune dans
les derniers mois parce qu'on est
vraiment dans les derniers mois on est
déjà en campagne en quelque sorte les
élections municipales sont un moment de
débat démocratique avec les habitants
c'est un moment où on discute beaucoup o
on parle de notre bilan où on parle du
programme on construit programme même
avec les habitants et ce moment-là
viendra assez rapidement mais
aujourd'hui de toute façon si vous
voulez à un moment donné on va pas
commencer à être en campagne un an avant
les élections imaginez il y a que 6 ans
dans un mandat donc c'est c'est c'est
quand même court et on est là surtout
pour travailler pour les habitants alors
vous n'êtes pas encore en campagne en
tout cas vous avez vous avez fait le
souhait d'être candidat est-ce qu'il y a
malgré tout un échéancier est-ce que ça
se prépare quand même une campagne ce
qu'il y a moi j'ai déjà fait trois
campagnes des de ma mais ce qui est très
différent aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai des
réunions avec mes administrés mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai comme question sur le
plan national je n'ai jamais été autant
interrogé sur les problèmes nationaux
dans le cadre d'une campagne oh là là
c'est c'est c'est c'est veut dire que
pour vous cette campagne municipale qui
va s'engager j'ai l'impression de
retrouver la campagne législative donc
c'est vrai que ça ça faut s'adapter je
m'adapte vous inquiétez pas mais les
français sont extrêmement choqués de ce
qui se passe en ce moment ils sont ils
sont même même même nos collègues
socialistes enfin je vois des militants
socialistes qui vous disent je suis
socialiste mais j'ai honte d'avoir voté
enfin qui a dit d'avoir voté pour une
une bande de fumiste pareil sur repain
ça a été repris d'ailleurs bon c'est
vrai qu'il y a un climat aujourd'hui qui
est très dur à gérer pour les él est-ce
que vous vous le ressentez-vous sur
cette votre commune ce ce climat où en
tout cas ces questions nationales que
peuvent se poser les habitants je suis
sur ma commune avec les habitants on a
assez de dossierers au niveau municipal
à travailler pour parler uniquement en
fait du dossier municipal après on sait
qu'on est sur une période de crise et
c'est tout le rôle des élus locaux de
pouvoir accompagner les habitants quand
je dis crise il y a une crise économique
il y a une crise aussi politique en tout
cas de confiance de confiance envers
envers les politiques et nous en tant
qu'élus locaux on est là pour les
accompagner et pour discuter au maximum
avec nos habitants parce que on est les
premiers élus auxquels ils ont affaire
et et cette proximité est
particulièrement importante puisqu'on
n'est pas forcément les mêmes que
d'autres élus qui ont fait de la
politique leur métier mais je reviens
quand même sur cette question sur
l'échéancier est-ce que quand même
malgré tout vous avez prévu l'un et
l'autre d'avancer est-ce que septembre
qui une date de rentrée est une période
importante pour amorcer un début de
liste amorcer un début de de programme
écoutez bien sûr on a classiquement une
mobilisation des gens dans ces périodes
c'est vrai qu'il y a une période
politique très très forte c'est clair et
du coup ça stimule les gens à venir nous
voir donc effectivement nous on a un
certain nombre de demande pour être sur
N List qui dépasse bien sûr le chiffre
de 35 donc c'est à nous de gérer cela
mais il y a une mobilisation
indiscutablement qu'on n'avait pas vu
dans d'autres campagnes d'accord un
échan constat j'ai un rassemblement
autour de moi donc ce rassemblement se
fait très
tranquillement et d'autres travaillent
autour de autour de ça septembre oui ça
sera la ça sera la rentrée scolaire ce
sera la rentrée des associations avec
notre forum et euh donc la rentrée
peut-être des candidats des ma des ma en
campagne on va regarder peut-être les
résultats du précédent SC parce que même
si au niveau national il y a une
incidence vous nous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et forcément on en parlera nous
aussi dans quelques instants avec nos
invités on vous fera réagir sur quelques
dossiers nationaux qui ont une incidence
aussi pour le quotidien des gens mais on
peut pas mettre de côté non plus les
résultats du précédent scrutin municipal
on va s'intéresser d'abord à à manie Lam
Jacques l on va voir les les
infographies dans quelques qu instants
voilàelle avait j'ai envie de dire
largement emporté avec plus de 63 % des
voix on va aller maintenant du côté
d'éancour alors peut-être que certains
ne s'en souviennent pas mais il y avait
une triangulaire pour ce deuxème tour au
municipal en mars 2008 et puis
Jean-Michel forous vous étiez vous aviez
gagné bien évidemment par devant Michel
bessau Parti socialiste etclaire Roussel
pour pour divers droite quand vous voyez
ces ces résultats alors je reviens
Bertrandon vous vous voyez Jacques lolos
élu avec 63 % des voix au 2è tour en
mars 2008 vous dites voilà c'est assez
confortable pour moi ça pourrait être
assez confortable ou sont les résultats
de Jacques lolos c'est pas les résultats
de forcément de Bertron Ouillon c'est
c'est les résultats d'une équipe à
chaque fois il y a un maire il faut il
faut pas trop personnaliser les choses
un conseil municipal c'est une équipe
c'est plus plusieurs personnes c'est un
SC liste effectiv vous avez raison
malgré tout il y a quand même une
personnalité qui dégage une tête de
liste mais les résultats des élections
proviennent aussi d'un bilan de
l'ensemble d'une équipe et je sais
qu'aujourd'hui le bilan de l'ensemble de
notre équipe depuis 2008 euh tout
simplement le programme qui a été
annoncé aux habitants en 2008 on a une
réalisation de 90 % de de l'ensemble des
éléments qu'on avait proposé aux
habitants voilà tout simplement début
avril ROR berger à manilé amau a demandé
à l'investiture UMP vous allez nous dire
comment vous réagissez voici l'interview
que nous avions réalisé au cours du
78 vous vous êtes engagé à à 16 ans à
l'UMP il y a une dizaine d'années vous
avez été responsable des Jeunes
Populaires des Yvelines avant d'entrer
au bureau national chargé de mission
également ce sera vraiment votre
première campagne pour vous présenter
vous-même puisque vous avez soutenu
plusieurs campagnes que ce soit celle de
de Valérie pcrè ou encore de François
Fillon dans les campagnes internes vous
avez le sentiment d'être légitime pour
vous présenter à une élection municipale
d'avoir le le vécu
suffisant je pense que je suis légitime
au regard du travail de terrain que je
fais à Mani il y a deux choses il y a à
la fois mon engagement au sein de l'UMP
en effet depuis un certain nombre
d'années même si je suis jeune et puis
il y a surtout l'engagement que j'ai au
quotidien à à manie à la fois un
engagement associatif un engagement avec
le collectif manie nouvelle énergie on
est là pour à la fois réaliser quelles
sont les difficultés quotidiennes des
Manis et surtout tenter d'y apporter des
des véritables solutions et élaborer un
projet de reconquête pour cette ville et
que nous présenterons progressivement
manquis l'opposition UMP sur votre
commune s'organise ça ne modifie pas
pour autant vos plans parler d'chanciers
tout à
l'heure ça modifie absolument rien on
est là vraiment pour travailler avec les
habit et pour les habitants donc pour
moi après chacun et sur cet adversaire
potentiel on la découvre puisque elle
est arrivée il y a peu sur la commune
donc elle
s'installe il a plusieurs mois VO
quelques années il y a 2 ans je crois à
peu près mais voilà c'est c'est une
installation je pense que si elle est
venue à maniléame c'est parce que la
commune de Manil lui plaisait
elle aura l'occasion de vous répondre
puisque nous organiserons par la suite
bien sûr sur cette antenne des
débatsours on va évoquer maintenant le
cas des l'encours alors effecement on l'
vu en mars 2008 il y avait une
triangulaire donc il y avait eu fort
fort AFF faire et puis dans votre liste
que vous aviez présenté en 2008 vous
aviez fait le choix de de l'ouverture
d'un grand rassemblement finalement je
le bilan que vous faites au bout de de
de ces de ces 5 ans d'ouverture
notamment je pense à à Dominique Lochon
qui était vraiment le le cas et qui
finalement a quitté votre votre majorité
oh écoutez j'ai beaucoup de N pas
fonctionné votretiouvert
simplement lorsque effectivement l'
avait pris sur not liste c'était mon
adversaire traditionnel social bon était
venu sur NL qui est assez effectivement
original et puis ensuite au moment des
des législatives là il y avait le le
face à faceace droite gauche elle est
quand même elle est quand même
socialiste bon donc céit m difficile
effectivement vous dites elle est venue
sur votre liste mais vous l'aviez
accepté vous étiez content de cette
ouverture aussi oui oui oui oui mais en
fait
pas elle pas ten entreillets je dire
c'est pas péjtif mais la longueurès
qu'il a une légtive o il y a le combat
gauche droite voilàelle savait pas
comment fonctionnait et donc là
effectivement on s'est séparé bon mais
très trèss presque globalement c'est une
leçon quand même que vous tirez de cette
politique d'ouverture de dire là c'est
SAR qui avait ouvert cela je regrette
que les
socialistes n pris aucun
ministre de droit si on veut réconcilier
les Français il faut faire des
gouvernements beaucoup plus ouverts que
celui on a fait d'ouverture bon écoutez
ça a marché à un moment ça a moins
marché après voilà on assume mais je
voulais dire à prop votre question sil y
a quelque chose quand même de nouveau
dans cette campagne aussi c'est le c'est
le chômage je n'ai jamais entendu parler
la crise de l'emploi euh du chômage
comme et et à priori je me suis rendu
compte que l' l'indicateur du chômage
même a en cours qui pourtant on a on a
quasiment doublé le nombre d'emplois en
cour sur TR mandur euh on est à 1512
chômeurs c'est du jamais vu dans
l'histoire des l'ancour or ce n'est pas
le maire mon cher collègue vous le savez
qui maîtrisons la situation je pense
c'est la même c'est pas nous directement
qui maîtrisons les coures du chômage
vous le savez l'activité économique elle
est quand même extérieure à une commune
mais je suis très inquiet et alors j'en
ai parlé avec mes collègues mes
collègues me confirment aussi qu'ils ont
la même montée hors norme du chômage
dans leur commune du jamais vu c'est
vrai du département il est vrai que le
département a été longtemps préservé
aujouri département plus on connait les
records de l'histoire he de no
communamment sur des sur des comme les
cadres nos administrés sont inquets ils
ont besoin que ce gouvernement euh
inverse le plus rapidement possible le
chômage redonne la confiance au Act
économ que les acteurs économies restent
sur place que on on on soit attractif
qu'on arrête de déclarer cette guerre
aux entrepreneurs aux investisseurs
comme on le fait actuellement il faut se
réconcilier avec le monde de
l'entreprise sinon on va perdre on va
perdre une grosse partie de nos emplois
et c'est un enjeu pour pour pour tous
les maires man tout à l'heure on
évoquait aussi le cas de Montini le
Bretonneux le maire ne peut pas être
avec nous mais vous avez enregistré
Carine une petite séquence avec tout à
fait alors il va nous nous dire s'il est
candidat ou pas on écoute c'est Michel
logier le maire d'ivers droite de Montin
le
Bretonneux je souhaite effectivement
conduire une nouvelle liste à l'occasion
des prochaines élections municipales de
2014 pour mettre en place un projet il
faut de T nombreuses années donc
aujourd'hui on a fait beaucoup de choses
sur la ville de Montini et moi j'ai
encore beaucoup chose à faire encore à
donner mais en attendant je vous dis il
y a beaucoup de travail et puis une
élection municipale ça se prépare donc
je vais le préparer avec bien sûr tout
le sérieux qu'il faut mais aussi avec
toute la dynamique qui est la mienne
parce que il faut choisir je vous l'ai
dit des colistiers il faut aussi avoir
un programme qui soit le plus cohérent
possible vous shaiez quelles
investitures pour écoutez moi jusqu'à
présent je n'en demande pas mais je je
les je je les reçois dont tous ceux qui
veulent investir la liste de large
rassemblement que je conduirai seront
les bienvenus en tout cas ma liste sera
de large rassemblement mais bien sûr
avec un positionnement plutôt de centre-
droit alors en tout cas pour le maire de
Montini lui ce sera une liste de large
rassemblement je sais pas si ça peut
vous donner des des idées à all en cours
en tout cas c'est ce que souhaite Michel
logier euh on va continuer dans cette
émission on est allé rencontrer les les
anciens mères donc ceux qui ont passé
euh leur le qu'ont laissé leur postees
en cours de mandat donc on a parlé dé
jaacqu Laios et a aussi pierre
sellincour du côté de de de laavrière et
Julie Rocha Suarez les a rencontré pour
le demander notamment comment ils
allaient s'impliquer dans cette campagne
des municipales de mars
2014 Manille etamo la verrière deux
communes une socialiste l'autre
communiste et de maires qui ont laissé
leur fauteuil après trois décennies de
mandat Jacques lolios a quitté ses
fonctions en septembre 2012 et Pierre
séincour en mars 2012 tous deux restent
conseillers municipaux comment
s'engagent-il auprès de leurs
successeurs pour les élections de 2014
Jacques Lolo assure avoir appris la
fonction à l'actuelle élu de Man
Bertrand Ouillon et dans les prochains
mois la situation se concrétisera
davantage je ser comité de soutien et je
je avec lui et avec les membres de la
liste j'animerai effectivement la
campagne électorale municipal de 2014
fais en sorte que donc
lui puisse appppuyer directement sur mon
bilan depuis tous ces mandats et qu'il
puisse donc bien faire comprendre aux
habitants que sil s'agit bien d'une
continuité une continuité dans l'action
dit-il de redressement de Manille Hamo
une commune aussi convoitée par Aurore
berger candidate à l'investiture
UMP à la verrière pierre séincour estime
avoir pris le temps nécessaire pour
assurer son remplacement par son premier
adjoint Alain ajage il y a un an je
serai dans la campagne sûrement pas
comme élu je ferai en sorte
que la liste qui tournera bien
évidemment autour de mon remplaçant
Alain Haage et les meilleurs résultats
possibles je pense qu'on dérogera pas à
la tradition dans cette ville depuis
1977 1 on a toujours une liste d'union
de la gauche 2 elle a toujours été élue
au premier tour toutes les élections
sans aucune exception les prochaines
élections municipales se dérouleront en
mars 2014 des anciens maires qui sans
aucun doute devrai occuper le terrain
les mois à venir
ce
conseil nous continuons cette nouvelle
édition de municipale 2014 rendez-vous
mensuel politique de la rédaction de TV
fil avec nos deux invités le maire
d'élencour UMP et le maire socialiste de
Mani lamoau nous allons vous faire
réagir sur quelquesuns des des sujets
nationaux qui ont une incidence
forcément sur la vie quotidienne la
moralisation de la vie politique c'est
un sujet qui fait beaucoup débat en ce
mois d'avril plusieurs annonces ont été
faites par le président Hollande après
la affaire Cusac c'était notamment le 10
avril pelmel a un procureur spécialisé
avec une compétence nationale qui pourra
agir sur les affaires de corruption de
grandes fautes fiscales des sanctions
plus fortes aussi comme l'inégibilité
définitive et il y aura également une
présentation le 24 avril d'un projet de
loi de moralisation de la vie publique
la vie politique est-ce que c'est
nécessaire et indispensable tout
simplement de remettre les choses à plat
on assiste aussi en ce moment à un grand
déballage les diff patrimoines vous êtes
prêt à présenter votre votre patrimoine
par exemple j'ai été interrogé
dernièrement justement pour savoir quel
était mon patrimoine j'ai répondu j'ai
aucune difficulté
là-dessus
mais surtout qu'on ne stigmatise pas en
fait les les élus plus riches un peu
moins riche et cetera c'est c'est un
sujet particulièrement
important c'est un sujet tout simplement
de confiance
entre la population les habitants et les
personnes qui sont à leur service en il
faut moraliser
euh on a assisté depuis depuis de
longues années à une
professionnalisation du milieu politique
euh un ministre très technicien dans son
domaine des élus qui ont en seule
activité en fait d'être élu euh qui se
forment pour ça qui euh euh qui font
limite des études en fait pour pouvoir
être pour pouvoir faire de la politique
et un un moment donné je le disais déjà
l' favorable ça cette
professionnalisation à un moment donné
on est élu on fait partie de la
population
euh à partir du moment où on en fait son
métier la seule ambition qu'on peut
avoir en étant élu par métier c'est son
ambition personnelle pour pouvoir garder
son métier et à partir de ce moment-là
ça peut poser problème je reviens juste
sur cette affaire tout mêmeac ça a causé
du tort au socialistes et pas uniquement
à l'ensemble de la classe politique
parce que qu'on vous interpelle dans la
rue pour vous demander par exemple votre
patrimoine ça aussi c'est inédit hein
c'est c'est ça cause du tort sur la
confiance justement entre toute la
population et les élus qui sont chargés
d'être au service des habitants donc
c'est pas eu c'est pas une affaire
uniquement uniquement au niveau du PS
c'est c'est une affaire qui euh qui
touche l'ensemble de la classe politique
et clairement aujourd'hui oui il faut
une moralisation de l'ensemble de la
classe politique et pas forcément euh je
le dis euh comme je le rapport à pas
forcément de des élus locaux qui sont
directement sur le terrain et
directement au contact des habitants
mais dans d'autres instances on a
assisté à cette fameuse
professionnalisation où des élus ne
pensent qu'à leur siège et pas au
resteousire sur la
morale contre
contre l'argent contre les chefs
d'entreprise contre finance disons que
l'enemi c'est c'est la finance écoutez
depuis 17 ans depuis 17 ans très bien
depuis 17 ans elle est en cours tris
mandats 17 ans 17 prix d'abord euh
aucune affaire de corruption ou de quoi
que ce soit je dis pas que ça a été le
cas de tous nos collègues socialistes
d'ailleurs et j'ai battu d'ailleurs
l'ancien maire quand je suis arrivé à
encour en 95 le point faisait sa Une sur
les villes de la corruption où il y
avait l'encour donc je peux vous dire
depuis 17 ans il y a pas eu la moindre
affaire me concernant bon donc VO la
moralisation je regrette que des gens
que les gens qui utilisent or moi je ne
m'étais jamais fait lire là-dessus mais
j'enis que des gens qui se fassent lire
se fassent lire se fassent fassent les
pires excès enfin un ministre du Budget
chargé de la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale qui a 15 millions 15 millions
sur un sur un compte
frauduleux je dirais que c'est c'est
très grave après l'affaire DSK que quand
même un drame un drame international ça
a baissé l'image de la France bon je
dirais que si vous trouviez un peu mieux
vous vous pvez sélectionner un peu mieux
vos candidats parce que c'est vrai que
ça devient pénible pour tous les gens
qui sont à l'international c'est
difficile en tout cas et dernier point
on a fait un sondage n en cours Ilop en
janvier bon le résultat inension de vot
c'est 58 42 58 pour nous 42 alors
c'était monsieur amont qui voulait se
prter à l'époque mais je crois qu'il a
il a il a un peu perdu du souffle je
sais pas comment dit-on il est ministre
l'ANT fait quasiment in 10 aujourd'hui
hein bon alors donc donc évidemment on
sent que les Français ont beaucoup bougé
les é en courtois aussi mais ce que dire
c'est que ce qui est surprenant dans ce
sondage c'est que par exemple on demande
quel est le critère que qu'il attribu au
maire le premier critère c'est compéten
87 % ce qui est important il y a pas 87%
des gens qui veent mais c'est
intéressant de voir que 87 % me trouent
compétente ce qui mais ce qui un c'est
pas pour vous parler de moi que je dis
ça
c'estz pas répondu à la question sur
laation monsieur on arrive lais
monsieurand on lui pose la même question
il y a des sondages il fait 27 % en
compétence 27 % des Français trou
compétent moi je suis 80 27 bon et comme
d'autres de mes collègues vous voyez ce
c'est c'est quand même drôle que cet
homme-là me donne à moi des leçons et va
me dire vous allez rendre transparent de
façon mon patr est transparent puisque
j'ai déjà été trois fois député vous
devez à chaque fois bien sûr déclarer
avant et après mais mais qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire des gens qui
instrumentalisent déclare que tout est
déclaré on l'a vu avec laaffaire kusac
he tout n'est pas forcément déclaré oui
mais dites-moi de toute façon aucune
aucune des propositions de Monsieur hand
ne ne règle le problème de Monsieur
kusac vous auriez eu le même monsieur
kusac après de toute façon c'est ne se
font pas vous le savez de toute façon
les socialistes même vos collègues à
l'assemblé ne sont pas d'accord mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire des gens qui
continuent ce qu'on demande à Monsieur
hand c'est ne plus jamais utiliser le
mot moral si vous voulez pas qu'on se
fâche entre nous on est quand même fait
pour pour pour travailler tous ensemble
demander à monsieurand de ne plus jamais
utiliser devant les électeurs français
pour éviter qu'il a des des mouvements
un petit peu agressifs de ne plus
utiliser ce mot voilà je vais vous jeis
vous laisser répondre si vous le
souhaitez juste également je voudrais
ensuite vous faire réagir sur cette
question du du cumul des mandats parce
que ça fait partie aussi de cette
moralisation globale peut-être être des
choses qu'attendent aussi les Français
les sacantinois les ivelinois faut-il ou
non cumuler les les différents mandats
et vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez
après est-ce que vous voulez répondre
sur cette question de de morale sur
cette question de morale il faut
peut-être aller un petit peu plus loin
que juste cette dernière affaire et à un
moment donné il faut aussi regarder
l'évolution de l'histoire très proche et
ce sentiment
justement de de grandes distance et puis
de de sortes de de protection ou d'aff
me de certains des élus alors je vais
citer peut-être certaines affaires qui
qui ont existé il n'y a pas très
longtemps des conflits d'intérêts qui
qui ont été soulevés notamment par la
presse on peut parler de de verte on
peut parler de de de sa femme qui qui
était
justement qui travaillait pour l'uréal
pour aider au niveau de la la
défiscalisation et cetera mais oui a pas
du blanc et du noir partout je met je
mets je mets pas les choses au même
niveau
justement
cabinetbing avocat d'affa voilà vous
voez voyez
voilà un moment
donné si vous voulez oui on pourit
pourrait faire on pourrait faire la
liste de tous les élus qui traînent des
valises ce et dans ce caslà là-dessus il
faut absolument que ces élusl justement
ne soient plus du tout éligible plus du
tout plus du tout al Jupé ne serait pas
éligible à partir de ce momentl oui vous
allez PIR vous envoyer la balle pendant
longtemps je pense Alain Jupé ne serait
pas maire de bord pour Berton il faut
plus qu'il soit égible voilà au MO une
question et vous allez me répondre juste
par oui ou par non sur le cumul des
mandats pourou contre le cumul des
mandats je suis contre et je toujours
été contre et en ce qui vous concerne
vous avez été député
mer vous savez Mo l'important pour fa
une répse très cour rest temp c'est
c'est la sécurité c'est le niveau du
c'est pas le C mais non mais le cumule
un député quand il va quand il est mer
il va il va mettre ses pieds dans dans
un peu là il sort de des de la partie
mequeté de l'assemblée il va avir moi je
ne suis pas contre si pour certains gros
exécutif oui mais un ma qui a une une
ville moyenne et un pe député c'est
compatible mais il faut pas que faut pas
que soit un conseil régional par exemple
voend c'est entendu Catherine on parle
des conseils communautaires très R ou
tout fait dernier dernier mot sur
l'élection des des conseillers
communautaires on parle des municipales
mais on oublie un peu le mode d'élection
des conseillers communautaires qui va
changer puisque quand les électeurs vont
se retrouver avec leur petit bulletin de
volte ils ont auront un système de
fléchage voilà qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de ce système d'élection des
conseillers communautaires puisque quand
les gens iront voter ils sauront qui
seront demain leur conseillers commun ça
peut faire changer le le scrutin ça peut
le faire évoluer c'est c'est surtout un
système qui pourra permettre aux
habitants de de comprendre plus
directement comment fonctionne une
agglomération et les différents
suffrages indirects font que on a
toujours l'impression d'un grand
éloignement de certaines structures par
rapport aux
habitants ça va permre ça peut faire
changer le
municipal pour l'élection du maire
est-ce que ça peut faire changer quelque
chose est-ce que les gens au moment de
voter qui vont se rendre compte bah non
tel membre sur la liste serait
conseiller communautaire au Parti
socialiste ben moi je ne souhaite pas
donc j'ai plutôt voter pour une autre
liste vous ne le craignez pas et même
chose après que ce soit je le crains pas
ça ça permet surtout de clarifier les
choses et les électeurs votent en âme et
conscience et je leur fais bien
confiance là-dessus non mais le côté
positif c'est que je pense que ça peut
peut-être un peu mieux équilibrer
éventuellement euh les les conseils
d'administration et le rêve pour une
intercommunaité c'est que c'est qu'on
arrive à 50 50 gauche droite ça
éviterait des des de faire rentrer des
militants massivement comme on le voit
dans cette casqu que mais voilà je sera
ce serait ser ce serait ce serait un
gain un gain de transparence de
démocratie vraiment de confort vraiment
et puis de respect de l'argent public je
vous rappelle que l'argent public c'est
l'argent du
contri la numéro de municipal 2014
rendez-vous politique de la rédaction
nous avons parlé de SaintQuentin lors
des prochains numéros on sir un peu on
parler
on parlera plus globalement desine merci
à vous merci à nos deux invités puis
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez revoir
cette émission sur notre site internet
également laissez vos commentair
rendez-vous donc le mois
prochain